[musique]
c'est un sentiment terrible de réaliser ça
sur le moment
Je peux dire que ma vie a été écourtée
tous les rêves, tous les objectifs ont également été écourtés
tout ce pour quoi je vivais a disparu en un seul
moment où je n'ai plus d'objectif que je n'ai pas
rêves
[musique]
J'avais un peu d'espoir que ce ne soit pas le cas
il aurait pu faire une erreur parce que je
ils ont dit qu'il avait une blessure au visage
c'était fatal et je pensais que
peut-être que le visage a été arraché et on ne sait pas exactement quoi
c'est lui mais comme il était à fond
tatouages
ses frères d'armes ne pouvaient le confondre avec personne
et ce jour-là à la morgue de Zaporozhye quand
J'ai vu sa photo dans ce bureau
Il m'a semblé que je suis mort avec lui
[musique]
Maman a pleuré et quand nous n'avons pas appelé et moi
se sentir compris
beaucoup de Nitro n'étaient rien quand on est de Poméranie
[musique]
Je ne sais pas, peut-être avez-vous déjà connu les prix, je
il y avait un os je crois toujours oui je pense
quoi devenir médecin de combat
parce qu'il a été blessé
incompatible avec la vie
s'il ne pouvait pas être sauvé, peut-être
pouvoir sauver quelqu'un d'autre
[musique]